-Our next guest can be seen
at the Historic Everett Theatre
in Everett, Washington,
this Saturday night.
Please welcome
the very funny Jackie Fabulous!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Hey, guys. What's up?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, I have so many milestones
to share.
I'm about to have really
high self-esteem this summer.
I'm going to Jamaica
to see my relatives.
Yeah! Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I tell women, if you want
to know how good you look,
how hot you are, go to
the Caribbean, any island.
You'll know how you look. Okay?
I'm very self-aware.
I know I'm like a life-sized
Cabbage Patch Doll.
I get it, right?
I used to live in California.
On that man scale of 1 to 10,
I know I'm a 6.
I get it, right?
In New York, I'm an 8.
I can cook. Y'all like that.
Okay? [ Laughs ]
But in Jamaica, I'm Beyoncé.
Okay?
[ Laughter ]
I am a 49.6 in Jamaica.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Okay?
I can't walk around.
It's not safe for me
to walk around in Jamaica.
Okay? And here's the thing.
I was working on a comedy cruise
and we had a port stop
in Jamaica.
I went for a walk.
Right? You shouldn't
do that by yourself.
And this man my age
chasing me on a bike.
A bike!
[ Laughter ]
And he's like, "Baby girl, where
are you going?
Let me show you the island."
I'm like,
"How? On your handlebars, sir?
How are you going
to show me anything?"
And another man running
after me, he's like,
"So where do you work?"
I said, "I work on the boat
there part time."
He's like, "Part time?
You give me your body,
I'll work on it full time."
I'm like, "Oh, okay.
Alright. I like it here."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Speaking of confidence,
I officially permanently moved
out of my mother's house.
Give it up for me. Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
You shouldn't clap. I'm 51.
That's sad. I shouldn't...
[ Laughter ]
And I'm going to miss my
mother's sweet, sweet judgment.
I'm going to miss her judgment.
She hates this job.
Her exact words were, "Jackie,
you know I hate comedy."
I don't know. That's like saying
you don't like joy.
I don't get it.
But she loves discussing
what I do with my neighbors
when I move back home.
Neighbors are nosy.
They're like,
"So what do you do
for a living now?"
My mom jumped in.
"Jackie is a joke!"
[ Laughter ]
She's like, "You know the card,
the funny man on the card,
the joker? That's Jackie."
I said, "Mommy, that's correct.
But what I do,
I'm called a comedian."
She's like, "Do you
tell jokes for money?"
Well, yes.
"Do you have a law degree?"
Yes, ma'am.
"Then you're a freaking joke."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
I'm going to miss that.
I'm going to miss her
weather reports every day.
Right? Because I used
to live in Cali.
I don't miss inclement weather.
She's like, "Jackie, you know it
rained on Monday.
Jacqueline, you know
it rained on Tuesday.
Jackie, you will not believe
this. It rained on Wednesday."
I get it, Mommy.
We share the same TV. I get it.
I can see what you see.
[ Laughter ]
I'm going to miss her very heavy
Jamaican accent, right?
She loves reality TV.
She would call me to discuss.
I don't know what show
she's talking about, right?
She's like, "Jackie,
I love that show Ardas.
The show on TV,
and the show is called Ardas.
And the lady on the show
has 85 pussies."
[ Laughter ]
I'm like, "What show
are you watching, Mommy?"
[ Laughter ]
And I'm like, "Wait a minute.
You mean 'Hoarders'?"
[ Laughter ]
The lady with 85 cats?
Your accent is jacked up.
I'm sorry.
[ Laughter ]
And FYI, they don't
call them that word anywhere.
They're called cats in
every country. I've checked.
[ Laughter ]
Another big milestone
since I was here last --
I got married! Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Love! Yes.
And I'm obnoxious.
You know, six months married.
I'm an expert, right?
So on Instagram,
pictures of he and I
and I'm getting DMs from women
now who want advice.
They're like, "Jack,"
because I married an ex-athlete,
ex-jock, you know,
a hot guy with muscles.
And they're like, "Jackie, how
did you find love at your age?
How did you find him?"
I'm real.
You got to find man
when they're at the end, okay?
[ Laughter ]
The more these guys'
bodies fall apart,
the more they want
to commit to you. Alright?
[ Laughter ]
When my husband's
left knee blew out,
he's like, "Jackie,
I have always loved you."
[ Laughter ]
When the right knee died,
"we should get married."
I'm not a fool.
Men get lonely, too.
You don't want to die alone.
I get it, you know.
But the one thing
we don't have in common
is that, you know,
the athlete who can cook.
We started dating,
and in the beginning of it,
at 12:30, midnight, he was like,
"So, um, do you want
a meatball sandwich?"
I'm like,
"It is 12:00 at night."
And he's like -- And I'm like,
"Of course I do."
[ Laughter ]
That's part of the problem.
But I'm feeling guilty.
When you have a hot guy who
lives in the gym, good shape,
you know, I'm not going to lie.
All this newlywed new stuff.
You know what I'm talking about.
I feel like --
I feel like he's killing me.
I feel like I'm dying.
Like I have a hernia
or a slipped disc.
I know when you go from nothing
to all of this, it's a lot.
Right?
And I'm worried.
I don't want him
to have a heart attack.
You can't have the person
in good shape
doing all the work
all the time.
He's always taking the lead
in the bedroom.
I'm like, "You know what?
I got to take the lead"
and give it to him
when he gives me.
So I decided to show him
that I can love him
the way he loves me.
So I did. Two weeks ago,
I gave him a great time.
I had been in pain
for two weeks.
[ Laughter ]
I have been talking
and making jokes
about men's stamina for years.
I apologize. Okay?
[ Laughter ]
I tried to do what you guys did.
I couldn't get through.
I needed a five-minute break.
[ Laughter ]
A granola bar, a Red Bull.
In the middle of it, I'm looking
for excuses to get a break.
I'm like, "You don't hear
that noise downstairs?
You don't want to go check?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
I'm like, "You're not hot?
You don't feel warm?
It's stuffy in here.
I smell smoke.
I don't feel safe."
[ Laughter ]
"There's a fire somewhere."
I'm Jackie Fabulous.
Thank you so much, guys.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Are you kidding me now?
Are you kidding me?
Jackie Fabulous!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're awesome.
See Jackie this Saturday night
at the Historic Everett Theatre
in Everett, Washington.
We'll be right back,
everybody. Come on back.